un nuevo intento de romper con el ciclo
de bloqueo político en israel este
miércoles el presidente del país hizo su
elección y este es el hombre al que se
le encargará la tarea de formar un nuevo
gobierno
y partido de centro de la isla
quedó en segundo lugar tras las
elecciones de marzo la cuarta votación
en sólo dos años el ex presentador de
televisión también recibió el respaldo
de cuatro partidos pequeños de todo el
espectro político
antes de la decisión de hoy su principal
oponente granata live nets jefe de la
mina un pequeño partido nacionalista y
religioso
la decisión llega luego del impasse que
volvió a enfrentar benjamin netanyahu y
la imposibilidad de asegurar una
coalición el primer ministro tenía una
ventana de 28 días tras la elección no
concluyente de marzo y esto le dio a sus
oponentes esta oportunidad de
potencialmente sacarlo del poder
luego de más de 12 años consecutivos de
netanyahu como primer ministro luego de
dos años de parálisis parece que quizá
dentro de pocos días y pocas semanas
podríamos tener una coalición funcional
que no incluya el señor netanyahu esto
será una ruptura en la historia reciente
israelí thing changing kristen tienes
ready vicente street el fracaso de
netanyahu resalta a largo plazo la
fractura de escena política israel y
tampoco logra asegurar una coalición el
primer ministro en funciones seguiría en
el poder hasta las próximas elecciones
lo cual le daría una oportunidad de un
mandato más